[Music]
we've got a great session for you today
so we're gonna cover specifically around
how retailers have prepared and plan for
a great peak season in this case Black
Friday on Google cloud platform so we've
got a lineup of two great speakers and
me here so my name is Kieran davuluri
I'm a customer engineer with Google
cloud I focus on retail customers
specifically we've also got Jimmy Dada
who's a VP of engineering at Cole's and
we've got Andre vittala who's the CTO of
Mackinaw a well known Brazilian retailer
so this is what we are going to cover
today I'm gonna walk you through the
importance of the peak session
specifically how you know a lot of
retailers handle Black Friday Cyber
Monday peak season and then I'm also
going to cover what Google cloud can do
specifically to help you navigate
through the peak season and make sure
that you plan prepare and execute for a
flawless peak and then I'm gonna hand it
over to jameth from Kohl's who's going
to cover the story of course and their
journey to Google cloud and then I'm
gonna bring in Andre vittala who's gonna
put the city of Matt Liu and he's going
to cover their digital transformation
journey and the amazing things they're
doing on Google cloud and lastly we'll
wrap up with you know some of the
resources that you all can use to be
successful on Google cloud so just
setting the stage right I know that you
know a lot of you are retailers and the
retail industry as a whole is going
through a pretty big transformation
right now and a lot of retailers have
seen sales slowing down in multiple
channels but ecommerce continues to be
one of the key areas of growth that most
retailers are see for example we know
that the e-commerce has sales have grown
to more than
two trillion dollars we know the
year-on-year growth for the sales is
more than 24% and this is the reason why
retailers are investing on their
e-commerce platform however when people
are investing in the reco most platforms
there is a lot of expectations from
customers on how an e-commerce platform
should look like the standards are very
high customers are now used to a very
high level of fast personalized service
we have studies that that have shown
that if your website takes more than
three seconds to load 40% of the
shoppers will abandon your website and
even if people have put their items in
the cart if the website crashes a
quarter of your shoppers are going to
abandon their shopping cart so what this
means is customer experience is critical
for retailers on their ecommerce sites
to differentiate themselves and without
a fast personalized consistent
experience it's hard for customers to
continue shopping on your website now
this becomes even more difficult when
you have a peak season like Black Friday
now retailers have understood that they
need to focus on e-commerce they've
invested a lot of money on their and you
know on the infrastructure required to
support their e-commerce websites
however it's still being very difficult
to accommodate traffic spikes for
example if you just look at the Black
Friday
that's happen retailers have had a risk
of about 300 million dollars of lost
sales due to application crashes and for
an average Fortune 1000 company we know
that infrastructure downtime on average
can cost a hundred thousand dollars a
year an hour on average so what this
means is retailers have a lot of money
riding on this and this is not just in
you know losses in terms of revenue on
sales
it also talks to the fact that you can
get in some cases negative press if your
website does not perform as intended on
a peak season when there's a lot of
eyeballs on your website but let's just
take a step back and understand right I
mean we know that retailers are
investing in e-commerce we have a lot of
I mean companies spend sixty two billion
dollars a year but why is it so
difficult to handle a large-scale event
like Black Friday it's not like Black
Friday creeps up on you I mean it's easy
to predict what you know when Black
Friday is gonna occur so let's take a
sample example of how a transaction
looks like on a set on a website traffic
the reason why it's so difficult to
handle the spikes here is you have a
baseline traffic that continues to be
stable and very very quickly it can
scale to five times your usual traffic
or more so your infrastructure
and your processes have to handle this
quick increase in load and continue to
serve the great experience that it did
even when the load was one-fifth of what
it was just a few hours prior and that
is a challenge so one thing that most
retailers have seen is hey the cloud can
help you Google cloud is very
well-suited for handling these sort of
things we have a great network we have a
secure scalable infrastructure but
that's not what I'm gonna focus on today
because you have tons of great sessions
that you can go to and understand how
the infrastructure itself can help you
scale but what I want to touch upon is
what else can Google cloud do to make
sure that you have a very good
experience and a flawless peak season on
Google cloud if you just understand the
let's assume that you guys are running
on an on-premise Hardware right
everything is within your control
the teams that run the support the teams
that run your network the teams that run
your infrastructure are all within your
control
but when you move to the cloud you're
now that is a sense that you are now
ceding control to other companies that
might not be as invested in your success
and that can cause some concerns and we
understand that so what we are trying to
do is figure out if we can be a trusted
partner with you guys and help alleviate
some of those anxiety and concerns when
you move to the cloud so what we have
done while working with some of our
retailers is developed a program that we
call peak preparedness program with one
simple goal our goal is to deliver a
flawless peak season for our retail
customers and I'll walk you through how
exactly we do that as you know for a
great event there are three distinct
stages we have a planning stage wherein
you define your objectives you look at
your architecture and know exactly what
capacity you would need to execute on
that you then have testing and adjusting
period where you run load test and
performance tests and lastly during the
event you will monitor and tune the
system to make sure that it continues to
meet these service level objectives that
you have set up for the system let's
take a sample Black Friday Cyber Monday
timeline and I'll walk you through how
exactly we help our customers here we
start engaging during pretty early right
we start engaging towards the August
mid-august end of August timeframe in
order to finalize the capacity plans by
this time most retailers have an idea of
how the traffic is supposed to look like
we continue to work with them and
usually we've seen that customers have a
code freeze around the end of September
October frame and then they go ahead and
during this time do a lot of load and
performance testing and this is critical
because it tells them how stable the
environment is and how effective the
the environment is in handling
unpredictability and we continue to work
with retailers alongside them in
addition to that one of the key things
that we offer is the tabletop exercises
now what we've seen whenever a
disruption occurs is it's not just a
technical issue that happens a lot of
times communication structures break
down and what we do with the tabletop
exercise is kind of simulate a disaster
in progress take an example of a
retailer's down Twitter's blowing up and
you know every hand is on deck but then
someone is not available for an
escalation path so what we do is we work
with customers and make sure that we
have a primary mode of communication
that set up and in addition to the
primary mode of communication we also
work with fallback options and in order
to make sure that even if something goes
wrong you always have a back-up plan and
the tabletop exercises have been
extremely critical for our customers to
be successful on peak once the tabletop
exercises are done we have a customer
infrastructure freeze the other area
where Google is well we differentiate
ourselves is the fact that we work with
our product engineering team to enforce
a code freeze around the peak weekend so
if you take the weekend of Black Friday
and Cyber Monday and before that as well
what we do is we work with our product
engineering to make sure that Google
does not push any new features or
enhancements the idea is we understand
the effort and investment that you are
putting on Google cloud and we want to
make sure that you guys have a great
peak season and this is something that
is very unique to what we do once the
code freeze is done you know you don't
have to worry about Google pushing
something and then that causing any
disruption the after that during the
scale down we continue to support you
all the way till the end of December
where when the shopping season starts
winding down
now if you've noticed one thing I have
completely skipped over our Black Friday
the actual weekend when it things happen
so for Black Friday what we do is we
make sure that you have access to all
the resources you need in order to be
successful so for example you have an
on-site account team so for certain
customers you can have your account team
be on-site supporting you so that you
know who to reach you have one single
channel of contact that you can start
helping to try at all your issues we
also have a fully staffed support team
we don't want our retailers to be in a
position where they are waiting on a
resource to look at an issue that's
happening so we fully staff our support
team and make sure that everyone's aware
not just of the technical knowledge but
also about the customers they are
supporting and what the potential
impacts could be so in addition to all
of this we also have essential be FCM
war room that is staffed by Googlers
from various organizations this includes
our professional services organization
this includes our site reliability
engineers this includes our engineering
and you also have channels into our
executive sponsors so what this means is
when an issue happens we are able to
very quickly bring the respective people
into a single room and try and make sure
that we can address any disruption
that's happening so as you all know
success is a team effort right and we
understand that customers when moving
from a traditional on-premise kind of
system they have these concerns about
hey how do I manage all these teams that
are there how do I manage my own teams
how do I manage all the teams that are
internal to Google and make sure that we
all work together and that's the problem
the peak preparedness program is
designed to address what we do is we
bring all the specialists all highly
experienced Googlers from different
teams
like for example our professional
services the account teams that work day
in and day out with you support teams
again highly experienced support team
personnel our customer reliability
engineering teams and representatives
from our product and engineering teams
as well and all of this with a single
goal of making sure that you guys have a
flawless peak season so we've talked
about how Google cloud has a program to
help customers navigate through this and
make sure that they are successful
during Black Friday what I'd like to do
now is bring our customers to talk about
their stories we've got two great great
customers here today we've got Coles who
you all know as a very famous US
retailer we also have mag Alou who is a
famous Brazilian retailer you've got the
CTO from there to talk to us about their
transformation journey so I'll first
invite Jim it for the VP of engineering
from Coles
he leads the DevOps and the data science
division for Coles ecommerce and Big
Data Platform and he's been a great
partner to us when Coles decided to
partner with Google cloud in 2017 his
team was one of the first teams to bring
their solutions onto Google cloud I'll
hand it over to him to walk us through
how they prepared for it and how they
plan for peak takeover Jim thank you
[Applause]
so as Karen mentioned you know Black
Friday for us it's it's a very important
thing coal's as most of you all know is
a leading omni-channel retailer we run
more than 1,100 stores in the u.s. we
you know we have stores in 49 states and
we provide a lot of you know so we
provide a lot of our own brands which we
run and a lot of other national brands
Nikes device a lot of them and you know
overall we make sure that the customers
are the primal most important you know
people for when they come to shop so all
our channels are in store or
omni-channel digital desktop mobile
tablet in-store experiences the
customers you know need to get the fast
response the expected response that we
are always ready for and that is one
thing that we really focus on and we are
committed towards we also do a lot of
you know give back to the community over
the years we have done almost 700
million of give back so you know we
really look at our primary thing of you
know make the customer prime you know
most important and our purpose is to
inspire and you know really empower the
families for them to live fulfilled
lives so you know I will walk you
through a quick journey right we have
been in the e-commerce business for
quite some time but we realized back in
2016 that we need to get out of the data
center business right how do we get out
of the traditional running our own data
centers running everything in front Prem
how do we manage all the network storage
availability everything else so we
started early we spent a lot of time
thinking about how do we break up our
ecommerce how do we dare ask ourselves
so that we can actually understand what
the cloud looks like we can take the
risk and move on so one of the things we
started was we moved our search platform
which was a traditional you know
technology running on
Oracle technologies to open source solar
technology moved it to the cloud got
some experience from it learnt on how to
manage cloud workloads what needs to be
done very soon after in 2017 we you know
pulled our search in browser experience
which is all our products how the search
works how you know your product detail
page your product matrix page and
everything else looks like we moved all
of those also to de cloud and that is
where we spent a lot of time
understanding you know how do we do you
know things like service discovery how
do we do things like secrets management
what are what the scalability really
mean to us right how do we identify
which regions which zones do we want to
run our workloads in so it really helped
us understand how complex the cloud can
be and what are the different things
that we can do to make sure that our
solution is always available actually
when we started in 2016 we thought we
will go to GK but then very soon
realized that we Kohl's as an enterprise
was not ready for GK right that's when
we had to switch back we moved to GCE
and pulled all our workloads on to the
global cloud engine just to make sure we
had much more control over it how do we
do things and then we managed it soon
you know after that in 2018 we brought
our cart and check-out our account
management which is the creel core of an
e-commerce business brought it over to
the Google Cloud this is where we had to
really focus on high availability we had
to focus on consistency with the user
experience user you know could be on any
server anywhere and they change a
password that should still be seamless
for them they can add payment it should
be seamless to them so we spend a lot of
time making sure our services are highly
available very scalable and we spent a
good amount of time learning cannery
releases Bluegreen releases and all the
other things that are a must when you
really move to a cloud solution right
within that we also realized a lot of
different things like you know we say
yes Google is also
but then sometimes our needs are very
different and typical example would be
we went to Google I alby's but very soon
realized that our workloads were not
well managed through the il B's you know
we could see some servers get a lot of
more requests than the other because the
ILP is typically work on a total you
know size of the packet versus for us
our user in sessions are so different
the new traffic looked very different so
we had to figure out how to put a proxy
in front of them just to make sure that
our traffic is well balanced and it
works seamlessly the way it needs to
this is where we really realized right
what and how do we build for the cloud
because cloud overall is is a really
awesome technology but it brings a lot
more complexities to us right think of a
networking team you know all of us if we
are running on Prem we are running our
own data centers we have one or two or
three networking guys to go to something
went wrong call this person that person
knows how a load balancer worked that
person knows how a firewall works that
person knows what to do when something
bad happens
guess what on the cloud that is not
really the same you open a ticket for an
SRE team that team knows VMs that team
knows you know the ILB is that team nose
security so this is where we had to
partner with Google we had to understand
all these nuances to make sure that we
are built and we understand how degraded
Mort works how we can quickly failover
and react whenever something happens
because Google being the great company
it is they provide us five nights right
99.999 percent availability guess what a
one-second impact to their network could
become a 10-second impact to my platform
so we really needed we had to understand
how to manage those and how to make
ourselves resilient because some of
things are going to happen and we need
to be ready to understand how to react
to it same things with compute platform
right they manage their own VMs there is
a lot of good CPUs cores everything else
is available behind the scene but then
things go wrong how do we identify and
how do we deep dive when your server
suddenly is you know is trapping for CPU
it's not able to scale we
to spend time we have to learn with
Google you know learn how to build the
resilient architecture that we needed
how to build the KPIs how to build you
know all the basic monitoring and
awareness of reacting fast to a problem
whenever it happens the other thing we
learned was sock outs right you know
again now the technologies are getting
better but when we started it was very
interesting where if one of the zone had
a stock out how do you react to it do
you stop building your cluster or you go
back and figure out how to you add
individual zones to a cluster and build
servers on just one zone right so these
are realities of the cloud which
unfortunately we only realize after you
start diving into it and after you start
working through it but you know again as
I said the technologies are awesome we
do need to change our thinking and we
need to change how we deal with it
because there is a lot of things that we
need to be aware of to get it done and
Google being the great partner they are
they really are there's through a lot of
it we you know when come back to Black
Friday right now how do we ensure that
our ecommerce platform is available is
ready for our customers to transact with
you know as I mentioned earlier
customers are the most important users
of our system and we need to make sure
that they get the best experience the
best performance and a seamless you know
checkout seamless login experience so we
really look at performance right from
the get-go for us performance is not an
afterthought it is something which is
really built into our DNA whenever there
is a new initiative that starts whenever
there is a new application that we build
whenever we look at anything that our
customer interacts with we put a lot of
focus on performance we make sure that
it goes through the lifecycle of you
know defining the NFS understanding what
the business goals are understanding
what the availability requirements are
go through the level of testing that is
required right different you want to
test features you want to test
scalability you want to test you know
the whole ecosystem and an integrated
view you also want to test and certify
production right you
you expected everything to work you went
through your SDLC you did you know dev
QA you know stress and everything else
but how do we ensure that things don't
go wrong in production you want to
really push it that's where we had to
think through how do we run you know
stress tests performance tests on an
existing production environment so we
had to go through all of this you know
and work through making sure that we are
able to give a very seamless available
platform to the customers peek again
this is where Kiran walked us through a
google timeline for us as I mentioned
peek is every day right we don't think
about peek and we don't wake up in
August September October to say okay how
should it look like monthly we do
releases we do a ton of changes in our
ecosystem in an environment and we
ensure every solution that goes out
there is fully certified it's fully
validated it is highly performant it
meets the business needs that are there
it can scale up scale down do all the
things that are needed it is highly you
know it is properly certified for the
use case that are there sometime June
July timeframe is when we kind of start
diving into okay business it's time for
you to give us your requirements
give us what your projections look like
tell us what you need I think you know
most of you guys if you are from the
technology area business things
differently they think about pikas
dollar value they understand they want
to you know sell X million dollars worth
of goods that doesn't really convert
into technology we spend the time taking
their requirements converting them to a
technology and converting them to a
measurable unit you know transactions
per second queries per second and
everything else that we need we really
do a deep dive to make sure that we have
built it and scaled our solution to the
point where it meets the business needs
after which we start you know running
our tests we figure out how the you know
traffic projection needs to look like
which component is going to get what how
scalable things are how does failover
work how does degraded mode work etc so
we do spend a lot of time in making sure
that we have done DHA we have done the
DR testing we have done certification
and we have certified the solution to be
you know completely ready we also you
know spend a lot of time in actually
trying to make sure that we are aware of
our dependencies being a retailer all of
us understand we have to depend on our
payment systems we have to depend on our
fraud systems we have to depend on all
the third-party integrations that we
work with right how do we do this
ourselves how do we make sure that we
understand when one of those systems
goes bad what do we do so we spend a lot
of time on it we build very clear
monitoring strategies we build very
clear you know rollout strategies as
well as you know how do we react you
know when something happens if it's bad
how do we not think about what to do it
should be a you know just a one two
three process so coming into September
October we actually run as if we are we
have Black Friday we run all the tests
we certify it we make sure we have
tested individual zones all the zones
within a region across multiple regions
how does things work if things go wrong
how do we react databases have a problem
caching system has a problem you know
any sub component has a failure what do
you do if your inventory system fails do
you stop taking the order or you figure
out how to put that order in a back lock
so that you can reprocess it right so
there's a lot of things that need to be
thought through and implemented and we
spend a lot of time making sure that
it's all done by end of September
because the most interesting thing is
September is the last functional release
that we kind of allow October and
November are purely performance only
make sure that everything works the way
it needs to and it is ready for Black
Friday Cyber Monday we worked very
closely with Google as Karen earlier
said their peers or teams their asari
teams CRE teams they came and showed us
how should we think about the SLI is the
SL O's how should we plan so that we let
the Google engineer during the time of
crisis be aware that this is the
dashboard they need to look at Google's
view of our system is only stackdriver
they don't understand our functionality
they don't understand
how we have build the systems so we had
to ensure that we have given them the
right KPI is the right dashboards the
right awareness that when I call
somebody at Google and tell them I need
help they can jump right ackley to the
area where they need to look at and help
us back so that the CRE and the asari
teams really helped us get there so that
we were ready for the Black Friday Cyber
Monday days when Kieran spoke about we
also you know had the teams available in
the office on hangout chats everywhere
else so that if something does happen
what do we do and as Karen said right it
was all planned collaborated tested we
understood what needs to be done and how
it needs to be done you know the
products that we use as I mentioned we
run most of the global you know cloud
engine we run their compute we run their
networks we run you know the big table
throughout spanner
you know big data proc all the
technologies that we have we are using
purely for the e-commerce areas
stackdriver
that's a pretty awesome tool there's a
lot of insights allows us to monitor
allows us to react allows us to get the
KPIs that we need to be able to help
understand where things are going and
how things are working out what's next I
think you know the the things that we
are focusing on this year is cost you
know I did skip through it but cost is a
very important problem right cloud makes
it very easy to say yes it's cloud
everything is available flip a switch
and you have your servers guess what if
you leave the switch on you keep on
paying for it we need to realize how to
manage this in our old data center ways
we never really cared about licensing it
was enterprise licenses stand up as many
servers as you want guess what when you
come to the cloud that might change so
unite you need to have a primary area in
the primary focus on it so we're going
to spend more time on cost management we
are also going to look at newer
technologies that Google has purely gke
you know look at you know their data
ProQuest is bigquery you look at areas
that we can now learn and grow to a
newer one we want to spend more time on
the
that is something which I'm assuming all
of us really want to get to is how do I
not get into managing a thousand servers
where somebody has to know what to do
how do I have a robot about running
behind the scene which can react and do
the things that are needed how do i
scale my system down every night how do
i scale it up in the morning so those
are the areas we are focusing on and
then you know scale our API platform we
need to ensure that the API platform
which we use which is also Google Apogee
is is highly available and ready for us
for peak
let me get given back on the screen
thank you
Thank You Jimmy I think that was a great
story of how you you know partnered with
Google we learnt a lot we learned a lot
together and you know Google cloud and
it thank you for being a great partner
to us I'd now like to introduce Andre
vittala
the CTO of magazine Luiza vittala as
he's known is responsible for leading
the technology and the digital
transformation efforts alongside the CEO
Fred Triana and he's been the primary
architect for the digital transformation
magazine lisa has transformed from a
brick and mortar retailer in who had an
e-commerce presence into an
industry-leading digital platform right
and magazine Luiza met or mugello as
it's known is seeing a double-digit
growth today compared to the other
Brazilian retailers in addition to that
it's not only seeing a double-digit
growth it's also holding its own against
all of the other digital commerce giants
that are trying to enter the Brazilian
market so I'll hand it over to him and
then he'll talk us about all the
transformation that they have done
so hello everyone Michael Liu or
approach is a business approach first
and then driven by technology so over
the past five years we have done a
complete transformation the company and
all the things about how many channel
like a pick up in store last mile
delivery mobile apps were sales
associate in our own marketplace
platform and we were able to do this
quickly because we used a hybrid
approach and the regional API is and
micro service in the company so we have
a great result too
one thing to point out is we didn't both
and the stores and our e-commerce
platform and together and we have our
jimothy of digital around 40% right now
and in the last three years the stock
price of the company grew 106 times it's
a pretty much the way that we see all
the transformation of the compra from
2015 to what we have now so talking
about the cloud that's all generating to
the cloud
actually we start in 2011 when we found
R&D team to start playing around with
new technologies in a different way of
development inside magazine Luiza and we
understand that the cloud is not about
only to reduce costs and scalability the
idea is it's although it's a benefit to
but the reason is that we need to
empower developers on our own the way
that we see and we need to to be able to
create fast and driver business vilifies
so last year we decided to do not just a
hybrid but also a multi cloud strategy
and we already using apogee and
kubernetes for some time but the last
year we decided to move all the data
workloads to DCP and we were really
happy with the applications on the CP
and
it's been great so far and then we
decide to move our e-commerce platform
as well so one of the really critical
piece of this strategy has been the
Apogee API management it's not just
infrastructure it's a critical strategy
to to gives speed agility and control
and so we can serve our customers and
manage business while at the same time
make life easier to develop in teams
and that that's a pretty much the grow
of API calls that we have on our
platform since 2000 said 2017 the
beginning of 2017 then after playing
around the data workloads on GCP we
decided to do something really crazy we
decided to migrate our e-commerce
platform apps to DCP just six days
before Black Friday and why here we
decided to do that is because we really
believe that we would have the best
Black Friday performance running on GCP
and we worked really tied with a Google
team the bissell team we have teams on
site on Black Friday help us to support
all the operation on the Black Friday
and we migrated 113 apps in just 53 53
days yeah and it's a lot of hard work
from the teams but it's paid off
it was our biggest and easy back Black
Friday
ever in the history of the company the
sales grew around six five 65% we have a
peak of close to 2000 or there's been
per minutes and all of huge numbers so
how that was possible for us to move so
quickly it's because
we are really believers of the
kubernetes since 2016 and it's enables
to move really quickly to hybrid my core
my multi cloud strategy we built in 2016
platform as a service called Theresa is
an open-source if someone is interest to
help us or collaborate to continue to
evolve the depth of our past and because
of today's we were able to just create
the clusters the kubernetes on GCP and
start moving our workload really fast so
that's a little bit of numbers of our
stack and GCP and the numbers that we
have in the peaks of Black Friday so we
reached almost eight eight thousand pots
and the peak and more than four the
fourth petabytes of logging and that
that month so it's a pretty much really
good numbers or off the stack about
products that are using today it's a lot
of GCP servers and we are using our DCP
servers today because I don't want my
teams thinking about infrastructure we
want to focus on delivering value to
customers and build software to drive
our strategy forward and the GCP has
been a great partner on this and we we
whatever we can use what we need and the
time that we think that is the best time
to the strategy so what an axe for
Mahalo
we are going to finish the migration now
for brick-and-mortar apps we have around
600 apps to move in 90 days and the
probability we're going to finish the
migrate by the end of May and then we
are planning to open our API that we are
calling a platform as a modulo as a
service and let the partners that we
have on our marketplace to use our
and centers and our stores to provide
the same experience that we are
providing to our customers for the one p
products so they can use our fulfillment
centers to store products and use your
logistics network to delivery and
same-day delivery or actually we have
35% of our deliveries in Brazil in the
in less than 48 hours you know you want
to provide the same thing for these
merchants that are using our platform
that's it
so back to the queue thanks for Tala
that was that was pretty amazing to hear
about your journey and your plans all
right so one of the things that you know
first of all thank you Jim it and fatale
afore sharing your stories with you with
us it's it's amazing to see how you know
the different paths and the different
ways that retailers can use to move
their existing applications onto the
cloud and you know essentially all we
are looking for is to make sure that the
customers can get what they want when
they want it and that is essentially the
goal of all of the retailers that are
that way and thank you for sharing your
stories and I would like you all to give
a warm applause to both jameth and Andre
because what they have done is amazing
thank you so for the audience what I'd
like to do is you know based on what
you've seen today do you feel that you
are ready for a peak season and if it's
not yes you know I'd love to chat with
you and talk to you about how we can
make whatever your concern are go away
and get you to an S and I'd love to work
with you all so what are the next steps
right so there are multiple steps that
you can take first thing is if you have
a Google account team please reach out
to them talk to them and they can help
you guide through the journey that is
required bring all the resources that
are necessary for you guys to be
successful we have
a brand-new retail website so if you can
go to G dot Kok / cloud slash retail
that's a new retail landing page and it
has tons of great content not just
around e-commerce but around all of the
value that we can bring to retailers on
Google Club and lastly feel free to
email me my email is over there I love
to have conversations with you and help
you out in any way we can and you know
point you to the right resources if that
is required we look forward to working
with you what since we do have a five
minutes you know I'd like to invite
jameth and Andre on stage if there are
any questions we can take some questions
if not thank you so much for your time
have a great last day at next
[Applause]
[Music]